meagan Markel and Prince Harry are
getting some pre-baby training
significance in your chapter the Sussex
duo stepped out on Sunday to attend the
christening of Lena Elizabeth Tyndall
the daughter of Harry's cousin Zara
Tyndall and her British hubby rugby
legend Mike Tindall according to our
royal source harry was recently named
godfather for cousin Zara's new daughter
adding that big brother william already
serves as godfather to the couple's
first child the adventure of a lifetime
the Duke and Duchess sweetly held hands
as they entered st. nicholas church for
the event
meagan stunning in a burgundy vintage
Dior coat from William vintage paired
with a navy Stephen Jones hat and black
Victoria Beckham bag while Harry looked
dapper in a dark suit and blue ties
Zara's mom Princess Anne and her
grandmother Queen Elizabeth also
attended the christening but no William
and Kate our source says the Duke and
Duchess of Cambridge were not in
attendance due to other commitments the
duo was spotted at st. Patrick's Day
events in West London last week
Buckingham Palace announced that Harry
and Megan have split households with
William and Kate although they
reportedly have not been granted full
independence from the palace this all
ahead of their move to Frogmore cottage
in Windsor I think the feeling is that
they're a bit on top of each other at
the moment by having both couples at
Kensington Palace it's not really giving
the Sussex is the chance to branch out
to to sort of step free of William and
Kate and do their own thing and I think
very much at the forefront of this
decision to leave Kensington Palace is
Harry's desire for them to have their
own court to have their own base and to
do their own things so I think relations
will improve with this move according to
our source the Sussex is are due to move
into Frogmore cottage provided the
renovation works are complete in the
next few weeks
adding quote the 10 bedroom cottage
which will include an eco-friendly green
energy unit includes two conservatory
extensions and extensive landscaping so
babies Sussex will have privacy you know
for so many years Harry was in Williams
shadow it's time now for him to break
free to do his own thing with Megan the
source says that Megan and Harry are
really excited about the impending birth
adding quote the baby is due in four to
five weeks time and Megan is feeling
great
Megan previously told well-wishers their
firstborn is do end of April early May
and last week shared they're nearly
there at a Buckingham Palace reception
last week the Duchess attended her last
official royal engagement before baby
Sussex arrives she and Harry stepped out
alongside William and Kate to celebrate
Commonwealth day I think we're going to
see more of Duchess Kate and now that
Megan is taking a well-earned maternity
break doing more engagements and really
putting herself behind this new mission
to help young people young vulnerable
people in Britain
[Music]